we're going to begin today with millions
facing a very icy commute today after a
brutal weekend of wild weather most of
us felt some of it nor'easter brought
heavy snow howling winds and coastal
flooding to much of the northeast
northeast rather there have been at
least four deaths connected to the storm
are amola langgate he's a very brave
soul rode out the nor'easter in boston
where almost two feet of snow fell on
saturday alone mo i know it was a long
cold weekend for you hopefully it's over
for you soon good
morning hopefully good morning gail yeah
the blizzard buried boston here and 23.8
inches of snow 23.6 of those inches came
on saturday alone tying the city's
single day snowfall record the snow
emergency that the mayor put in place
just expired about an hour ago
the powerful nor'easter swept up the
coast with raging winds frigid
temperatures and coastal flooding the
streets officially flooded
blizzard conditions were reported in at
least six states we have high winds
before we've had high tides before but
it's the wind it's the tide it's the
snow it's everything all at once and
more than two feet of snow in at least
three states
staunton massachusetts recorded more
than 30 inches
sea spray from the massive waves along
the coast encased homes in brant rock
with ice
this is a satellite photo of the east
coast sunday morning you can see snow
stretching from south carolina to maine
[Applause]
parts of the island of nantucket were
inundated with flood waters the cold
temperatures even went as far south as
florida coating some fruit and ice and
freezing iguanas it still looks a little
cold
thousands of flights were canceled
on sunday it was all about digging out
back breaking and for some
having fun
well the snow isn't going away anytime
soon as temperatures aren't supposed to
get above freezing until at least
tomorrow and if that isn't enough nate
another storm system is in the forecast
bringing even more snow
and freezing rain on friday
mola thank you so much and please
go inside and get warm because you do
look very cold we appreciate you